اعنف المعارك واطولها امدا تشهدها مدينه
بخموت بالشرق الاوكراني القوات الروسيه
تسعى الى السيطره عليها منذ الصيف الماضي
لكنها تواجه صمودا كبيرا من قبل
الاوكرانيين
قوه تتلقى تدريبا من قبل بعثات اوروبيه
على استخدام دبابات الالمانيه كما نرى في
هذه الصور لكن ميزان القوى يظل في صالح
الكفه الروسيه تقول قياده بعثه الاتحاد
الاوروبي التدريبيه
نوضع اذا كان في الاوكرانيون الان في وضع
دفاعي ضد اكثر من 300 الف مقاتل روسي
في الوقت الحالي هم كذلك يقاتلون من اجل
باخموت انهم يقومون بعمل جيد لكن ميزان
القوى ليس في صالحهم
من اجل بخموت تحاول القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بذل اقصى ما يمكنها لالحاق
اكبر قدر من الخسائر بالقوات الروسيه كما
يقول الرئيس الاوكراني